Speaker 1: So one of the things that's at
issue in the Alex Jones defamation trial award
phase is Alex Jones claim of bankruptcy.
Now, Alex Jones is not bankrupt.
However, Alex Jones has filed for bankruptcy
and he has even admitted that part of it is
in order to shield or protect certain assets
from the potential settlement that is coming,
the potential award that is coming for the
defamatory statements that Alex Jones made.
One of the things Alex Jones tried to do during
his testimony is to claim I am bankrupt.
And the judge actually directed him to stop
saying that that he is not bankrupt, that
he may have filed for bankruptcy, but that
he is not bankrupt, and he can't continue
to say that.
Yesterday, Judge Maya Guerra Gamble actually
talked to Alex Jones about what sort of a
settlement do you believe would be fair?
And Alex Jones trying to beg for mercy, saying
even $2 million would sink Infowars.
Now, that's sort of hard to believe, given
that it's on record, that Infowars would sometimes
make $800,000 in a single day.
But check out this incredible exchange.
Speaker 5: What compensation would you believe
to be appropriate?
Speaker 3: What compensation do I think appropriate?
Despite these numbers that were presented,
the best we ever had that we fell in scoring
and there was a run on historical food nationwide.
And so they.
Mr. Jones No, I'm just saying.
Speaker 5: We don't.
Speaker 3: Like improvization.
Speaker 5: What you believe to be appropriate.
It doesn't really matter about that.
Speaker 3: I understand, but I can answer
a question.
However I wish I my barred from talking about
where we're at financially.
Speaker 5: No, you are at this stage right
now.
The question is what compensation would be
appropriate?
Speaker 3: Any compensation above $2 million
will sink us and will be shut down.
No.
Speaker 5: Appropriate or not, you are appropriate
for what happened.
Speaker 3: I mean.
I mean, I think it's appropriate for whatever
whatever you decide you want to do, because
I'm really proud.
Speaker 5: That's a great answer.
Thank you.
Speaker 6: But this is.
Speaker 1: Just like I've never seen anything
like this.
And again, the question is, based on the acts,
what do you believe is appropriate?
And Alex Jones is saying we can't afford anything
over $2 million, which also, by the way, seems
to be a lie.
One of the other things that's been going
on and then we're going to go to a break and
we're going to get back to a little bit of
this later.
Actually, one of the other things that's been
going on is that, again, while the trial has
been taking place on his program, Alex Jones
has been saying things about the trial, the
judge and the jury and the judge also making
an effort there to probably to prevent a mistrial
or subsequent appeal by asking direct questions
about the members of the jury.
Speaker 5: Are you aware that this jury consists
of 16 intelligent, fair minded citizens who
are not being improperly influenced in any
way?
Speaker 3: Yes.
I don't think that you are operative.
I don't think that you are part of a false
flag that.
Speaker 1: Even Alex Jones, no matter where
he goes in life, he can't get away from this
false flag operative stuff.
He's now in a defamation trial and he has
to clarify.
He's not saying the jurors are part of a false
flag.
Speaker 3: You are bad people like good people.
And I just am very, very critical about the
whole process that I've been through so far
where I've given I believed everything over.
And then I'm always told we didn't even know
we're seeing it.
And so that's why I'm really concerned, because
a lie has been misrepresented.
Speaker 4: He wandered off the question.
Speaker 5: Do you feel you're getting a fair
trial?
And if not, why not?
Speaker 3: But.
I'm barred from saying so simply.
Speaker 5: Please.
Speaker 3: I have been found guilty by a judge
and I find America found guilty by juries
or hamsters.
Speaker 5: No guilt or innocence.
Speaker 4: In civil court.
But you couldn't write something that read.
Speaker 1: This is just unbelievable.
Speaker 3: I understand.
Libel or not.
Speaker 5: So please don't use that.
You're not a lawyer.
That's fine.
Speaker 3: Well, I've been found liable, so
by a judge.
And this end and all the other cases coming
out of Oregon.
So this is a dangerous new system they're
setting up.
And if people want to get rid of that and
get rid of America, it's okay.
I understand we're in Old Republic.
May be time for us to go.
Speaker 1: Get rid of America.
If Alex Jones has to pay up because of the
things that he said, it's the end of America,
folks.
Incredible, unprecedented.
And just dozens and dozens of emails from
people in the audience pouring in about this
insanity.
And we'll get back to a couple other elements
of it a little bit later in the show.
If you're curious about what these clips look
like and you're just listening today, you'll
be able to find these clips on our Instagram
David Pakman show.
Find us there.